[Música]
quiero terminar el trabajo esa ha sido
la frase principal entre los argumentos
que dio el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden al anunciar su intención para
aspirar a la reelección y permanecer en
la Casa Blanca por cuatro años más el
anuncio no fue una sorpresa ya era un
Secreto a voces ya de hecho era un rumor
del que ya todos estaban comentando en
los pasillos en diferentes sectores
políticos en Estados Unidos pero una vez
el presidente biden hizo este anuncio
comenzaron todo tipo de análisis
críticas burlas rechazos y también
apoyos
una presidencia con tantas calamidades
es casi inconcebible que Joe biden
siquiera considerara ser candidato a la
reelección ustedes saben lo que pasó en
la anterior elección hicieron trampa y
se robaron las elecciones pero les
prometo esto cuando debatamos y
comparemos nuestros historiales va a ser
la peor pesadilla de los radicales
demócratas porque nunca ha habido un
récord tan malo como esto y nuestro país
nunca ha estado peor nunca ha habido un
contraste tan grande entre dos
administraciones en la historia de
Estados Unidos con la de nosotros siendo
grandiosa y la de ellos un fracaso Tal
parece que Joe biden no tiene rival al
interior del partido demócrata entre
tanto en el bando republicano Donald
Trump como ustedes lo veían suena como
candidato potencial pero también los
nombres de Nicky hayley y de ronde
santiz aspiran a obtener la nominación
por ese partido así las cosas el debate
en Estados Unidos se ha enfocado en
torno a la edad del presidente Joe biden
muchos consideran que es muy avanzada
para continuar en la Casa Blanca otros
han hecho un balance de su gobierno y
sobre sus verdaderas posibilidades de
ganar
estoy un poco molesta es un poco viejo y
si no puedo unirme al ejército a los 58
No creo que él deba gobernar el país a
los 80 y cuántos años tendrá 84 es
demasiado viejo definitivamente
demasiado viejo Entonces qué significa
cuatro años más del gobierno de biden en
Estados Unidos para temas clave como por
ejemplo migración la guerra en Ucrania y
la relación con América Latina estamos
ante una especie de déjà Vu o una
especie de repetición también podemos
decir de una elección disputada entre
Joe biden y Donald Trump qué balance se
puede hacer de la administración de Joe
biden al día de hoy y también se
pregunta uno si los demócratas no
construyeron a lo largo de estos años la
imagen de un sucesor para biden y es el
el único que puede obtener esa
nominación hoy en el debate de France 24
analizamos la aspiración a la reelección
del presidente Joe biden en Estados
Unidos y para comentar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a JP Carol él es
estratega republicano también es
analista para seguridad nacional y
gobernanza inclusiva en el centro Joseph
raini para políticas públicas también
está con nosotros Aníbal Romero él es
estratega demócrata y abogado de temas
de inmigración nuestros televidentes
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook también
nos encuentran en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_s la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo también
para terminar les recuerdo que todos los
contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la palabra a
jappie Carroll nuestro primer invitado
en el programa de hoy y Bienvenido al
programa JP Gracias por estar con
nosotros y cómo recibieron ustedes y
cómo recibe usted y qué análisis hace de
este anuncio esta aspiración a la
reelección por parte del presidente Joe
biden
Bueno gracias por la invitación un
placer estar contigo mira creo que como
lo dijo correctamente en su introducción
esto no era una sorpresa sabía que iba a
presentar su candidatura el presidente
de y ya se veía que iba a utilizar este
mensaje de acabar o sea el trabajo que
está haciendo que el uso ese mensaje
durante su discurso ante el congreso del
estado de la unión
[Música]
ahorita
la cosa es que para los demócratas es la
única opción y a este tema de edad del
cual hablaron varias personas en su
introducción es un tema lo cual es una
crítica que se puede hacer hacia el
presidente pero también hacia el
expresidente Trump entonces creo que
esta elección se va a marcar
desafortunadamente por realmente una
falta de entusiasmo para los dos
candidatos más probables para cada cada
partido siendo eh para los demócratas y
Trump para los republicanos lo único que
notaría
adicionalmente es que mencionó las
candidaturas de Nick halleyentes también
añadiría una mención a la candidatura
mejor dicho la exploración de una
candidatura como un no ha anunciado una
campaña totalmente es el senador
de Carolina del Sur el cual creo que
tiene mucho entusiasmo y apoyo del
partido republicano en Washington pero
hay que ver aún Si eso realmente se
traduce en votos en las elecciones del
proceso de las primarias el partido
republicano es la perspectiva de JP
Carol pasó a darle la palabra a Aníbal
de nuestro siguiente invitado bienvenido
también al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros Punto de partida Cómo
recibe usted este anuncio esta
aspiración a la reelección cuatro años
más posiblemente de gobierno Joe
Sí bueno primero Bueno buenas tardes
gracias por la invitación efectivamente
como dice JP será una candidatura sin
entusiasmo Pero esto Existe en este
momento él es el titular en este momento
porque es el presidente de Estados
Unidos y sabemos que ese concepto del
titular significa mucho porque es muy
difícil que un presidente que
actualmente esté en su cargo pierda una
reelección ha ocurrido pero es muy
difícil entonces en realidad
efectivamente insisto como dice JP será
una candidatura que hablará mucho de
terminar su trabajo Yo creo que en el
fondo
la ventaja que tiene el presidente Joe
biden es que en este momento el único
que suena con posibilidades de ganar en
el partido republicano es el presidente
ex presidente Donald Trump y sabíamos
que esa postura de extrema derecha
realmente es muy difícil de llevar a
Estados como
que son los estados que van a dar la
presidencia lo que creo que también hay
que tomar en consideración que todavía
falta mucho falta un año nueve meses
para el para las elecciones muchas cosas
pueden pasar en un año nueve meses si
las elecciones fueran el día de hoy creo
que ganaría las elecciones nuevamente
porque insisto lo importante aquí es
mexicans sabemos que los han mejorado
bastante en la en la Florida y los
demócratas han mejorado en Estados como
Arizona en Georgia se va a decidir las
elecciones nuevamente en mexicano y creo
que el presidente de esos estados Qué
son los estados que nos mantienen en
vilo normalmente en estos momentos
electorales o cuando hay elecciones en
Estados Unidos Aníbal continuó con usted
para preguntarle por lo que se vive al
interior del partido demócrata otra vez
a Joe biden como candidato o por lo
menos aspirando a esa nominación y a esa
reelección deja muchas preguntas en
torno a como decía yo en la introducción
del programa a lo largo de estos años de
gobierno biden tampoco se construyó o se
fortaleció alguna figura al interior del
partido para poder hacer un relevo del
presidente biden muchos pensaban que iba
a ser kamala Harris pero la vemos que va
a seguir a la sombra de biden en el rol
de vicepresidenta muchos pensaban que
tal vez podía hacer ella la candidata o
algún otro
de este partido porque el partido
demócrata le está apostando el todo por
el todo a biden
Bueno lo que pasa es que en este momento
él es el presidente de los Estados
Unidos y tradicionalmente cuando un
partido está manejando la casa blanca
sería un poco difícil que un candidato
en las primarias quiera tumbarlo no por
llamarlo Así es un candidato es verdad
de poco entusiasmo pero en este momento
es lo que existe ahora
Acuérdese también que este es un tema de
percepción percepción en el momento Es
verdad que hoy en día no tenemos O al
menos se percibe que no existe un
candidato Pero eso nace de la noche a la
mañana vimos la candidatura de Donald
Trump que nadie pensaba que iba a ser
presidente de los Estados Unidos y irse
de cero a cien en cuestión de meses
acuérdense cuando era presidente Obama y
la campaña de Trump se enfocaba
básicamente en decir que Obama no era
americano era una burla que en ese
momento si ustedes me hubieran
preguntado Miss que Trump va a ser
presidente en dos o tres años me hubiera
reído Entonces yo sí creo que hay
personas en el partido demócrata está
que todavía Pues no ha tenido un
protagonismo real real vamos a ver qué
pasa en los próximos cuatro años pero
también está
podrá salir otro eh miren estas cosas de
la noche a la mañana empezamos a
escuchar de de cierto candidato y las
encuestas créame con la ayuda de la
prensa y con redes sociales empieza a
replicarse y de repente tenemos el
próximo presidente Obama como lo tuvimos
en ese entonces que nadie lo conocía era
una persona de héroe que había perdido
unas elecciones locales para el congreso
luego ganó el senado y pasó a ser
presidente entonces creo que estamos un
poquito
creo que sí es prematuro como usted dice
falta todavía un año y nueve meses para
estas elecciones JP Carol de toda del
otro lado de la balanza ustedes ya se
les empieza a aclarar un poco el
panorama para los republicanos entender
cómo empezar a mover las fichas a lo
largo de este año y nueve meses que
tienen para llegar a ese momento
de las elecciones en este escenario ya
como están las cosas ya entendiendo que
yo baiden aspira la reelección entonces
de estas cartas que yo mencionaba al
inicio que usted agregó a Team Scott a
este senador de una de las carolinas
quien puede ser Entonces ese candidato
que puede ponerle el pie a esa
candidatura de Joe biden y puede entrar
a disputar esa silla presidencial
bueno según las encuestas por el momento
el candidato o sea la única otra opción
con
que tiene números interesantes digamos
ni siquiera bueno necesariamente es
interesantes en las encuestas de la
republicano es el gobernador de santis
pero ahí o sea va la situación de que
las últimas semanas ha habido publicidad
negativa contra él el expresidente Trump
ha comenzado realmente enfocarse en
realmente
atacar al gobernador de santis y con eso
eso allí quizás hay la oportunidad para
que surja
la ex embajadora ante la ONU o el
senador Carolina del Sur y ahí hay la
oportunidad pero precisamente
como se dijo hace un momento que
o sea nos falta bastante tiempo hasta
las elecciones hasta ni siquiera las
primeras primarias y creo que se debe
anotar mirando esto de una perspectiva
histórica que cualquier presidente que
se ha presentado para una campaña de
reelección el cual ha
tenido o sea competición dentro de su
propio partido para la nominación
siempre ha perdido la elección general
desde la presidencia
cuando se presentó el senador Kennedy de
ahí vemos el presidente Bush padre quien
perdió contra Clinton y tuvo que ganar
la nominación de su partido por la
candidatura de El señor en fin el hecho
de que en este momento el presidente va
en o sea tiene competición de
Marian williamson y también el hijo del
senador Kennedy su hijo Robert Kennedy
Jr creo que eso realmente le debe de
preocupar no realmente de que no va a
ganar la nominación Pero simplemente en
tener que invertir tiempo y recursos en
simplemente ganar la nominación de su
propio partido eso le quita el enfoque
de ganar la elección general para el
lado republicano la otra cosa con el
expresidente Trump son o sea estos estas
situaciones
inciertas que tiene en las Cortes en que
no se sabe que va a ser el resultado
final de estos varios casos que hay
contra él en Nueva caso federales y con
eso Quizás vamos a ver un gran cambio en
las encuestas y quizás un aumento de
apoyo para deshantes
O sea que aún falta bastante tiempo
hasta que damos que va a ser la
situación exacta en en el otoño en Sí en
un año digamos en un año JP continuó con
usted para preguntarle por el que se ha
generado en Estados Unidos también en
diferentes partes del mundo incluso lo
estaba comentando Yo hace algunos
minutos con colegas En la redacción de
France 24 y es el tema de la edad del
presidente aquí nos está evaluando sus
logros como mandatarios sus desaciertos
como mandatario a lo largo de estos años
que sirvan para evaluar su gestión como
presidente de Estados Unidos en un
momento en el que Estados Unidos pues
necesita
afianzar su liderazgo a nivel
internacional y también dar solución a
muchos temas internos pero el debate en
la sociedad estadounidense ha girado en
torno a la edad cuando por ejemplo un
candidato opositor como podría llegar a
ser Donald Trump Pues tampoco es que sea
mucho más joven que el actual presidente
Joe biden Entonces porque esta
importancia de la edad y por qué tratan
de jugar esta carta en diferentes
sectores como un punto negativo y
dejando de lado una experiencia de
muchas décadas a nivel político y pues
que además está actualmente ejerciendo
el cargo
creo que cada partido político en este
momento o sea republicanos y demócratas
están intentando de crear apoyo para el
futuro y con esa mente quieren quieren
alcanzar y atraer a votantes más jóvenes
y entonces a lo al corto plazo creo que
ellos piensan que una manera hacer eso
es destacar como un punto negativo la
edad del candidato del partido en el
cual están en oposición pero
precisamente como ha dicho o sea esto es
un tema para ambos partidos con el hecho
de que ambos partidos O sea la persona
más probable de ser nominada por cada
uno va a ser a alguien que es bien mayor
o sea no no veo que que le sirve
realmente a cada partido
criticarse el uno al otro de esta manera
lo único que creo que realmente destaca
es la necesidad de cultivar nuevos
candidatos una nueva generación de
candidatos para el futuro después de si
realmente invertir recursos en
apoyar a gente joven para que
decidan a presentarse para candidaturas
a Estos tipos de puestos y creo que una
de las grandes cosas que realmente hace
las personas dudas y digan si deben de
meterse en la política son esos tipos de
ataques que vemos que las campañas se
lanzan una contra la otra de manera muy
muy negativa y si alguien Mira esto y
viene una vida confortable con su
trabajo y y ya sirven a su comunidad de
otras maneras más discretas porque o sea
someterse ese nivel de de o sea
publicidad simplemente para ataquen a
uno y es muy triste Aníbal y que piense
usted al respecto este tema de la edad y
todo este debate que se ha despertado en
Estados Unidos
a mí no me preocupa la edad a mí me
preocuparía más bien la Salud Mental del
presidente de cualquier candidato hasta
el día de hoy no tengo ningún indicio de
que el presidente está preparado para
liderar el país hasta que cumpla ochenta
y seis años es simplemente un número mi
mamá tiene 95 años está perfecta mi papá
tiene 78 y como que no está muy bien
entonces el tema de la edad el número en
sí no me preocuparía mucho Yo creo que
como dicen el compañero el señor Carol
es verdad tienen que cultivar a a nuevos
personajes a nuevas figuras políticas
porque la verdad nos damos cuenta que
ambos partidos tienen un serio problema
de identidad a veces el otro día
comentaba con amigos que en realidad en
Estados Unidos parecería que existen
cuatro partidos
políticos no existe la extrema derecha o
como los demócratas lo llaman los
trompistas
existen personas de Centro en ambos y
también está el el La ola de alexandro
Castro y Bernie Sanders Entonces yo creo
que el partido tiene que decidir Para
dónde va ambos partidos no yo creo que
el partido republicano tiene un serio
problema porque el que lidera las
encuestas es el presidente Trump y está
liderando con un mensaje bastante
radical y me preocupa para el futuro del
partido republicano que tal vez si el
presidente Trump no es el candidato
realmente la gente no va a salir a votar
porque van a seguir pensando que hubo
fraude en las elecciones y van a
preferir quedarse en casa entonces hay
que ver qué pasa Yo creo que nuevamente
insisto creo que el presidente va a
ganar la reelección y la verdadera
pregunta va a ser qué va a ser del
partido demócrata en el para el 2021 Esa
es la verdadera pregunta creo que no
mucho va a pasar en los cuatro próximos
años sinceramente en ese orden de ideas
an y poniendo en perspectivas ese
escenario que usted plantea de una
posible disputa presidencial entre el
expresidente Donald Trump y el actual
presidente Joe biden aspirando a la
reelección Cómo cree usted que va a ser
esa campaña Y esa disputa lo que vimos y
el tono que sea impuesto en la política
de Estados Unidos es ausencia de debate
ausencia de ideas y de propuestas y
ataques frontales entre un candidato y
el otro noticias falsas denuncias sin
argumentos enhalamientos y una pobreza
de debate político que incluso Ha
logrado trascender las fronteras de
Estados Unidos y lo vemos también en
algunos países de América Latina donde
los electores nos quedamos esperando
propuestas para solucionar
verdaderamente los problemas y se quedan
en ataques ideológicos que pues a la
hora de la verdad eso no resuelve las
situaciones y las complejidades que
viven los países estamos Entonces como
decía yo en en la introducción del
programa viendo un déjà Vu una
repetición de la película que ya vimos
sí efectivamente es lo que vamos a ver
Me da mucha lástima este tipo de ataques
creo que le conviene al partido
demócrata porque sabemos ya lo conocemos
al presidente Trump sabemos que va a
repetir sus discursos va a ir a ciudades
donde él es bastante fuerte para tratar
de crear esta imagen que le están
apoyando en el país pero realmente las
elecciones se van a decidir en estos
estados de Merche
creo que el partido demócrata tiene que
realmente trabajar la Florida Es
realmente Increíble como perdieron
realmente al Estado de la Florida vemos
que ahora el gobernador de Santos es un
gobernador muy querido en su estado y lo
hemos perdido porque por muchas razones
el partido demócrata ha fallado con la
comunidad latina en el sur de la Florida
Esto es algo que lo tienen que ellos
tomar en consideración pero a su vez han
ganado lugares importantes como Georgia
Arizona
entonces creo que así funciona no lo
importante aquí es que Creo yo que la
economía está en un muy buen
lugar sí existe una percepción pero por
regla general la gente está trabajando y
las personas quieren estabilidad y creo
que la van a conseguir con el presidente
y por eso van a salir a votar por ya
vamos a hablar de esos logros y
desaciertos que ha habido a lo largo de
esto de este mandato del presidente
biden hasta el día de hoy
JP paso a preguntarle por el partido
republicano por esa aparente división
que hay interna entre esas entre esos
sectores del partido republicano que
apoyan más de cerca al expresidente
Donald Trump en esta aspiración a una
nueva aspiración presidencial que ya han
sido denominados los republicanos maga
haciendo referencia a make American y
ese otro sector del partido que tal vez
preferirían un punto de vista político
renovado un poco más actualizado menos
extremo Por decirlo así y hay cierta
división esto para elegir a ese
candidato A esa nominación va a generar
problemas al interior del partido qué
análisis puede hacer usted
Definitivamente hay gran división dentro
del partido o sea el hecho de que el
expresidente o sea le está yendo bien
las encuestas contra otros republicanos
o sea eso no importa nada cuando lo
comparas a las encuestas de cómo sería
la elección general o sea todas las
encuestas muestran claramente que entre
el presidente vainil expresidente Trump
está ganando el presidente va en cada
vez en cada encuesta o sea yo creo que
hay gran posibilidad de
desafortunadamente que el expresidente
Trump sea nominado sea el nominado para
el partido republicano para la
presidencia precisamente porque hay
tantos candidatos que se están
presentando o sea contra él que esos
candidatos entre ellos van a dividir el
voto
contra Trump Digamos si va a ser más o
menos O sea una repetición como has
dicho muy bien déjà Vu de pasó en 2016
en que si miras a lo que pasó ahí no es
que él ganó
51% o 60% de los republicanos el proceso
de las primarias en Tuvo más o menos O
sea de manera sólida treinta y cinco
cuarenta por ciento y lo que ocurrieron
aquí los otros candidatos dividieron lo
que quedaba del voto entre ellos o sea
que realmente solo hay espacio para un
candidato que no sea Trump realmente
unir a el resto del partido en contra
del expresidente pero creo que se va a
demorar un poco para que ese tipo de
cosas ocurra y quizás va a tener que ser
una situación parecida a lo que hicieron
los demócratas entre ellos de manera
estratégica en 2020 donde todos
decidieron salir del camino del ahora
presidente
antes de la elección primaria es
importantes de Carolina del Sur y lo
cual aseguró para que él tuvo la
victoria allí y ya
empezó a ganar directamente contra el
senador para en fin ganar la nominación
del partido demócrata y creo que les
haría muy bien a los republicanos que se
oponen al expresidente de aprender de
esa lección claro eso en cuanto al
partido JP Pero qué hay de los votantes
hemos visto en las últimas elecciones a
un Estados Unidos muy polarizado muy
prácticamente dividido casi que en
partes iguales entre apoyos a las
tendencias republicanas y otros hacia el
lado demócrata Pero qué hay para los
apoyos para una eventual candidatura del
presidente del expresidente Donald Trump
de ser nominado por su partido llegaría
a una elección con con juicios y
acusaciones federales
una personalidad muy muy compleja para
para entender que a la luz de la
comunidad internacional
las relaciones pues se tensaron un poco
con algunos de los grandes aliados de
Estados Unidos
eso fue lo que dejó en buena parte esos
cuatro años de gobierno Trump no lo digo
yo lo decía por ejemplo La cancillera
alemana Ángela Merkel en su momento que
la relación con Alemania de Estados
Unidos ya no era la misma desde que
Trump había llegado allí a la
presidencia y pues tampoco mucho más
joven que biden 78 años tendría si
llegara a esa a esa presidencia a ese
segundo
en la presidencia en Estados Unidos hay
apoyos en la sociedad estadounidense
apoyo sólido en bloque al expresidente
Trump
es suficiente apoyo para que él sea
nominado para el partido republicano eso
creo que o sea si pasaría mañana él
sería el nominado para el partido pero
para el país en general si cuentas con
votantes independientes
demócratas que no están a favor del
presidente biden Yo creo que él va a
perder él siendo el expresidente Trump
va a perder la elección general contra
el presidente baile entre los puntos que
ha destacado con estos juicios pero
también más que todo yo diría
el impacto de sus acciones
antidemocráticas en el seis de enero de
2021 y también
la respuesta ante ante el coronavirus y
hoy día entre esos dos temas es por eso
que él nunca más va a ser presidente de
mi opinión
bueno importante esa declaración ese
punto de vista de JP Aníbal continuó con
usted para hacer un poco de balance de
lo que ha significado esta estos años de
presidencia de Joe biden al frente de la
casa blanca al frente de Estados Unidos
citaba algunos algunos temas importantes
de la agenda
qué significarían entonces cuatro años
más de Joe biden en temas Como por
ejemplo migración la llegada de
migrantes a través de la frontera con
México la guerra en Ucrania Trump dice
que si él llega a ser presidente
nuevamente la guerra se acaba con biden
qué escenario tendríamos y
otros temas a nivel interno que podemos
ir analizando más adelante pero
Comencemos con esos dos de la coyuntura
internacional
sí Bueno definitivamente solo para
aclarar yo soy demócrata pero no soy
fanático y me encanta poder debatir a
alguien como JP Caro que yo no entiendo
porque el partido republicano no tiene
más personas como él sensatas que dicen
la verdad Porque a veces veo la
televisión y no puedo creer las cosas
que están diciendo en muchos a favor del
presidente Trump pero estoy
Completamente de acuerdo Yo les
agradezco a ustedes dos que hay hay
balance en el debate y hay altura en los
argumentos en los puntos que ustedes
están exponiendo no siempre tenemos la
fortuna de tener un análisis político de
altura como el que están haciendo
ustedes adelante Aníbal Gracias y por
eso empiezo diciendo eso porque es
verdad que el presidente biden casi
seguro para mí va a ganar pero Hay
muchísimo que tiene que trabajar
especialmente en el tema migratorio
sabía que era un tema muy importante
para los demócratas lo ha ignorado por
completamente no se escucha
absolutamente nada tengo entendido que
ya se va una de
vamos a ver quién entra ahora para ver
si podemos Escuchar algo más de
inmigración que es un tema que realmente
Afecta no solamente a los migrantes que
no votan pero le afecta la economía
vemos que se ha firmado con republicanos
un plan de infraestructura que van a
necesitar trabajadores para poder
progresar en los próximos 20 años y
realmente creo que el tema migratorio va
a ser tan importante para eso crear
posibilidades para que puedan venir
migrantes de forma legal y no estar
cruzando la frontera como lo están
haciendo ahora en el tema migratorio
creo que ha fracasado por completo
Obviamente el el tema de Ucrania y de
Rusia es mucho más complicado El Putin
no se va a ir tan fácilmente yo soy muy
creyente en las instituciones del estado
y creo que en ese sentido pues la
administración conjuntamente con los
servicios de inteligencia saben Cómo
manejar tema muy bien pero no va a ser
nada fácil Rusia no nos va a canchar la
cabeza así de fácil Entonces tal vez
tengamos cuatro años más de noticias
sobre ese tema y en el tema económico
vamos a ver obviamente hay una tasa de
desempleo que ha bajado muchísimo pero
la inflación Eh sí ha mejorado tal vez
este año pero hay que ver qué pasa hay
muchos expertos económicos que hablan de
una posible recesión en los próximos dos
o tres años
vamos a ver qué pasa pero son temas
demasiado importantes que el presidente
vaya con su equipo tiene que trabajarlos
si es que piensan ganar una candidatura
en el veinte veintiocho Porque ahí sí
creo que el partido republicano va a
estar mucho más preparado porque ya no
existir es la figura de Donald en ese
sentido la cifras Tal parece que
acompañan al presidente biden recibió el
desempleo en el 6.3% en este momento en
Estados Unidos están 3.4% la inflación
pues está alta pero desde la Casa Blanca
argumenta que está bajando poco a poco y
también tiene bajo la manga ese plan de
la ley de infraestructura para
modernizar los aeropuertos puertos y
autopistas para hacer un país aún más
competitivo esto ha generado muchísimos
empleos y una inversión Pues también muy
alta por parte del Estado por parte del
Gobierno Federal JP veamos entonces La
otra cara de la moneda las deudas
pendientes el tema migratorio pues ya lo
pone Aníbal como tema básico de esta
deuda pendiente que arrastra el gobierno
biden Pero qué más se le queda por fuera
y que se le puede volver un dolor de
cabeza en esta candidatura
creo que entregué las situaciones que
quizás van a ser más problemáticas para
el presidente
contra la China y eso va con el tema
económico
y creo que si las personas a pesar del
hecho de que sí las cifras muestran
claramente que las cosas están mejorando
pero si las personas no lo sienten
van a buscar razones por la cual no lo
sienten y creo que el partido
republicano
son muy muy buenos en o sea presentar
[Música]
como le diría presentar o sea narrativas
de de cuáles son cosas que no
necesariamente son causas directas pero
de asociar un problema con otro y o sea
juntarlos en la mente de votantes
digamos y creo que ellos van a muy
efectivamente tratar de hacer eso con la
situación económica doméstica y la
política hacia la china
también de manera parecida con la
situación Ucrania aunque creo que la
mayoría del republicanos como la mayoría
de Estados Unidos estadounidenses en
general le tiene mucha simpatía la O sea
horrenda de guerra ilegal sin
justificación de Putin y Rusia contra
Ucrania
si si el pueblo estadounidense no sienta
que las cosas van bien económicamente
dentro de los Estados Unidos van a mirar
a todo el dinero que se compartiendo en
el esfuerzo de apoyar a las fuerzas
armadas en Ucrania y van a comenzar a
hacer preguntas de qué se podría hacer
mejor con ese dinero de los Estados
Unidos muchos republicanos al tema con
que comenzamos ya han estado también
haciendo esta pregunta y vinculándolo al
tema de inmigración O sea que ya ya
veremos por definitivamente
no va a ser fácil estar reelección este
intento reelección para el presidente en
línea con lo que usted dice JP añado a
esta lista de deudas pendientes pues lo
que usted decía de China la relación con
China y el incremento de tensión en los
últimos meses a raíz de ese apoyo a
Taiwán y el despliegue de recursos
militares allí en el Pacífico ha tenido
muy tensa esa relación con Beijing y
también pues por el tema de Rusia que
recibe el apoyo de China Yo también lo
pondría En esa lista como parte del
Análisis la relación con América Latina
Estados Unidos ha estado muy distante de
la región a lo largo los últimos años y
también ese llamado que tiene Estados
Unidos por ser una gran economía a nivel
internacional y es justamente el
liderazgo internacional que poco a poco
Estados Unidos ha cedido justamente ante
China y entre otros actores
internacionales me queda un minuto y
medio para terminar el programa hagamos
las conclusiones para para el cierre
comienzo entonces con Aníbal para
continuar la la ronda en este sentido y
conclusiones lo que vamos a ver entonces
en esta campaña vaiden como candidato y
un escenario con muchos meses previo a
lo que puede ser estas elecciones en
Estados Unidos pero que nos puede dar un
panorama general adelante y yo creo que
el el mayor beneficiario de estas
elecciones nuevamente será los medios de
comunicación porque habrá show
no queda más yo creo que el presidente
va a ganar Las primarias habrán otras
otros estados y competencias que
iniciarán acciones penales en contra de
él
tendrá que defender sus cuatro años que
para muchos como decíamos anteriormente
ha sido con muy poca emoción pero eso es
lo que vamos a terminar viendo el
próximo año estoy preparando para los
discursos claro es completamente de un
lado y del otro sin ninguna política
Clara
Lamentablemente eso es lo que esperamos
el show que es parte de estos procesos
electorales en Estados Unidos en los
medios estamos acostumbrados a cubrir
este tipo de eventos electorales en
Estados Unidos con toda la parafernalia
que esto involucra VIP su conclusión
para el cierre Sí gracias dos cosas uno
creo que esta elección se va a tratar
más que todo sobre la economía y segundo
quien se fuerza en conseguir el voto de
la comunidad hispana en Estados claves
va a ganar
importante ese punto esa anotación el
voto hispano que siempre es relevante en
estas elecciones en Estados Unidos Pues
a JP y Aníbal les agradezco mucho por
haber estado con nosotros haber hecho
este análisis
puntual de altura sobre todo sobre este
panorama político que comienza a
configurarse allí en Estados Unidos a
raíz del anuncio del presidente Joe
biden de aspirar a la reelección por el
lado de los demócratas ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales Pueden seguir
también dejando sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales sobre este tema En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos la sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncell y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera sigan
dejando sus comentarios y sigan
comprando
[Música]